.
ANTHONY?
>> MANUEL, THANK YOU.
>>> WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS FROM
RUSSIA WHERE OPPOSITION LEADER
ALEXEI NAVALNY JUST MADE HIS
FIRST PUBLIC APPEARANCE IN
WEEKS.
IT OFFICE A VIDEO LINK FROM
PRISON.
ELIZABETH PALMER'S FOLLOW COULD
THE NAVALNY CASE FROM LONDON.
THIS COURT HEARING WAS VERY
REVEALING.
>> Reporter: THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE SEEN NAVALNY SINCE
THAT HUNGER STRIKE.
HE LOOKED GAUNT.
HIS LAWYER SAYS HE'S LOST 50
POUNDS.
HE HAD A PRISONER SHAVEN HEAD
BUT WAS AS DEFIANT AS EVER AS
HIS WIFE YULIA AND A HANDFUL OF
REPORTERS LISTENED.
HE CALLED THE CASE AGAINST HIM A
FORGERY AND TOLD THE COURT,
REFERRING TO PRESIDENT PUTIN,
YOUR KING IS NAKED.
LEGAL EXPERTS HAVE CALLED HIS
IMPRISONMENT ABSURD.
HE WAS CONVICTED FOR VIOLATING
PAROLE.
BUT THAT WAS BECAUSE HE WAS IN A
GERMAN HOSPITAL AT THE TIME
RECOVERING FROM AN ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT WITH THE RUSSIAN NERVE
AGENT NOVICHOK.
AND TODAY AS YOU MENTIONED, HIS
ORGANIZATION HAS ANNOUNCED A
FRESH CHARGE AGAINST HIM WHICH
SOUNDS EQUALLY ABSURD -- SETTING
UP A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
INFRINGED ON THE RIGHTS OF
CITIZENS.
NOW CLEARLY THE KREMLIN WANTS TO
SHUT DOWN NAVALNY'S ANTI-PUTIN
MOVEMENT.
IT'S TRYING TO BAN IT BY
LABELING IT EXTREMIST.
NAVALNY HIMSELF IS SAYING HE
WILL FIGHT ON BUT FROM BEHIND
BARS HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO AVOID
BEING SMOTHERED BY THAT GROWING
MOUNTAIN OF LEGAL RED TAPE.
GAYLE?
>> OH,